(upbeat music)
- All right let's finish
up this hour of spookiness
with one last story to give
you goosebumps, hopefully.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
Many people go all out with
their Halloween decorations,
but one family seems to have
everyone pretty much beat
with their "Stranger
Things" inspired decor.
Their front yard has been
completely transformed
into the Upside Down world
with many of its creepiest creatures.
But the true highlight is this.
It's the spitting image
of the character Max
being mysteriously levitated
10 feet in the air.
It's awesome.
And it looks pretty close to
the actual scene in the show,
so that's pretty cool.
So let's meet the family
behind this special effects masterpiece.
Everybody say hi to Dave and Aubrey
and their kids Brooke and Gage
celebrating Halloween as their favorite
"Stranger Things" characters.
(audience cheering and clapping)
All right, so Dave, happy Halloween.
That looks like it's really levitating.
So how did you pull that off?
- Well, that's a secret
I think we're gonna keep
just a little bit longer
until Halloween's over.
It's something we did for the community
so we really wanna kind
of keep it under wraps.
Once our video on TikTok went viral
I think it's at like 14 million views now.
Keeping it a secret was the hardest part
and really we pretty much
have just been telling people
that she's made of pool
noodles and grocery bags
as well as most of our
"Stranger Things" set up.
Pretty much all done in pool noodles.
The support has been unbelievable.
- It's so cool.
So how long did it take
to put this all together?
- So it's really been a full-time job.
It took us about two months to
get up and build everything.
But the best part is we're
able to do this as a family
and we love Max as a character
and we're just happy to
see everyone else loves her
just as much as we do.
How did you help Gage?
- I helped glue things together
and...
I was very happy we could do this.
- What about you, Brooke?
- I helped us sample and paint things
including the vines
and it's just crazy that
we're basically global
in the entire world.
- I love y'all so much. What a fun family.
Thank you so much for sharing this with us
and also with your whole neighborhood.
That's so cool.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
- And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen makers of FriXion
the ghost erasable pen of
the "Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like y'all.
So they're giving you $1,000.
You can put that towards
your next Halloween.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my god.
- How's that for global?
(imitating air horn)
(chuckling)
- Thank you.
- No, thank y'all so much.
We love y'all, we appreciate it.
Thank you to all our guests today,
Rose McIver, Loni Love
(crowd cheering)
- Brittany Briar, and Creepy Chloe.
And a huge shout out to
everyone in the department,
art department, lighting,
production, producers.
Everybody involved did such a great job.
My band, everybody killed it.
We couldn't have pulled
off this incredible hour
without each and every one of
you on this staff thank you.
Y'all have a great Halloween
and if it's not try and change it.
We'll see you back here tomorrow.